tras aterrizar en una base aérea
estadounidense al sur de seúl el
presidente joe biden se dirigió
directamente a una fábrica de chips
informáticos de samsung para reunirse
con su homólogo surcoreano yoon sung
yeom y una muy pro estadounidense
llevaba un tapabocas con las banderas de
corea del sur y eeuu al reforzar los
lazos de washington con seúl la visita
de biden forma parte de un plan más
amplio para contrarrestar la presencia
de china en la región de
esta vibrante democracia se ha
convertido en una potencia mundial en
innovación al investigar y educar a su
pueblo así que este es el momento en mi
opinión de invertir unos en otros de
profetizar en nuestros lazos comerciales
y acercar a nuestro pueblo
walker sin embargo la cuestión de la
seguridad en la península de corea es la
que domina la cumbre de líderes ya que
corea del norte ha aumentado sus pruebas
de armamento descongelando los test de
misiles balísticos intercontinentales
el departamento de estado de eeuu
asegura estar preparado para una posible
provocación durante visita de vaivén
nuestro servicio de inteligencia refleja
la posibilidad genuina de que se
produzca o bien un nuevo ensayo de
misiles incluido un ensayo de misiles de
largo alcance o bien un ensayo nuclear o
francamente ambos en los días previos
durante o después del viaje del
presidente a la región denis rafter
beijing vaivén dejar a corea del sur
para ir a japón el domingo donde se
unirá a una cumbre regional del quad una
alianza que compone en japón eeuu india
y australia